Speaker 1: Hey, here's another one that's floating
around. Senator Ron Johnson, a Republican from
Wisconsin, appeared on Fox News and said there
is not an FDA approved COVID vaccine in the U.S..
Now you might be wondering, wait a second,
they they just approved the Pfizer vaccine.
What are you talking about? There's emergency
use authorization for JNJ or Johnson,
as some people like to call it, for Moderna.
And there's a full approval for Pfizer. Ron
Johnson says there isn't now his his explanation
is nuts, but I'll explain to you what we're going
to hear from Ron Johnson here. He says what was
approved was Core Manatee, which is the vaccine
that Pfizer sells in other countries. But
that's not what's actually available here. Now,
this has already been debunked, but let's listen.
Speaker 3: It's right down this country. Roughly
70 percent of 75 percent of the country
has gotten a single shot, just about
says. Sixty five percent have gotten hep
vaccinated. So consider that fact that within the
natural immunity, we're at herd immunity right now
joining you in this legislation, Senator Loomis,
Senator Roger Marshall, Utah Senator Mike Lee
and looks like Dan Crenshaw is moving something
on the House side. Has any Democrat expressed
they want to join you? No, no, there will be
all kinds of different peace legislation pushing
back on this mandate, but Brian, something else to
tell America, we do not have an FDA approved
vaccine being administered in the U.S..
Speaker 1: OK, now listen carefully here.
Speaker 3: The FDA, you know, played a bait
and switch. They approved the comandante version
of Pfizer drug that's not available in the US.
Even admit it. I sent them letter three
days later going, What are you doing?
What they do is extending the emergency use
authorization for the Pfizer vaccine that's
available in the U.S.. Here it is more than
30 days later. They haven't asked that very
simple question. If you're saying that the
Pfizer drug is the same as the comandante,
why didn't you provide FDA approval on that? So
there's not an FDA approved drug? And of course,
they announced it so they could push through
these mandates so that people actually think,
OK, now these things are FDA approved.
Speaker 1: So the first thing you have
to ask yourself is why? Why would they do that?
What? What would be the point? I'm I'm trying to
buy into the conspiracy. I guess if you believe
that, that's what happened. You would believe it
on the basis that. They couldn't really get the EU
way U.S. Pfizer vaccine approved because something
is wrong with it. So they submitted approval
for Corman Adi, which is the Pfizer vaccine
in other countries, but that was not. Now it's
just it's just a lie. OK. This has been widely
looked at. It's been looked at very strongly.
Nebraska Medicine has a very specific article
addressing this question. I've heard that the
FDA said Pfizer's commonality, common Nattie
and BioNTech formulas are distinctly different
in their vaccine approval letter. Is that true?
Infectious disease pharmacist Brian Alexander
writes No in terms of what is contained inside
the vial of each. They are identical. Pfizer
and BioNTech simply formerly branded or named
their vaccine Komar. Natti BioNTech is the German
biotech company that partner Pfizer to bring it to
market. Pfizer, Komar, Natti and Pfizer-BioNTech
COVID 19 vaccine are biologically the same thing.
They are chemically the same thing. The confusion
stems from this section of the FDA's vaccine info
one. The licensed vaccine has the same formulation
as the EUA authorized vaccine, and the products
can be used interchangeably to provide the
vaccination series without presenting any safety
or effectiveness concerns. Concerns the products
are legally distinct, with certain differences
that do not impact safety or effectiveness.
The FDA desires to have a single combined
vaccine information sheet. A single sheet keeps
things simple for people giving the vaccine and
getting it, since the branded and unbranded vials
are chemically identical despite being legally
distinct. This information must be included. The
the it's just been debunked, and it's another one
of these things that they feared, who else but
the low information Fox News audience? Brian Kill
Me doesn't have the wherewithal to question it or
maybe doesn't have the interest in questioning it.
But. A week ago, five weeks ago, this has already
been out there. It's already been debunked.
It's not true. And again, this is another
one of these things where, wow, Ron Johnson
researched it and he found answers. He felt he
exposed something this is like. Sometimes you'll
see a post on Facebook and it'll say something
like, Hey, you know what? COVID doesn't like.
Beet juice and you know, all you got to do
is drink beet juice every day and you're
going to be fine. I've been drinking beet juice
since the start of the pandemic. I haven't gotten
it. It's like, Wow, they missed everything. Is it
airborne versus droplet? And does it? Where is the
infection happening and indoors? They won't tell
you that beet juice kills it. There are medical
discoveries. Medical discoveries happen, and
sometimes they are. They're counterintuitive or
whatever the case may be. But the arrogance with
which some of these folks present the findings
of their quote research is really something
to explore sociologically and psychologically